You know,
a little bit easier.
What is it like when a one of those giant
tubes crashes down on top of you? Um,
yeah, so this game Medina, um, he,
he ended up winning the contest. Um,
it's not super fun when you eat.
It could imagine it's, I mean,
you've probably talked to Shane
and that's me actually. Yeah,
I've talked to Shane about it.
Yeah. And I mean, look, Shane,
no one's more of an authority than
Shane is. Maybe not in the super hollow,
crazy stuff. I mean, whatever.
Shane writes everything.
But the biggest waves in the
world change the authority.
Like he's had wipe outs
that he came close to dying.
He probably talked about
the vest he created because
of that, he almost drowned.
He created a vest that you pull a CEO
two cartridge and it blasts, you know,
this big bladder and
lifted to the surface.
Even if you get knocked
out or taken water,
someone's going to find you and probably
save you. Um, but yeah, this is,
that's me there. So I didn't make
that, but that wasn't even a big one.
You're not for that day. That was
a small way of fucking huge though.
When that's coming down. See where
I'm at, I'm kind of in blue water,
so I was able to dive and kind of get
under it, not get sucked back over.
So there's a little bit of a
skill that goes with wiping out,
so you understand that energy.
It's, you know, it's like a,
it's like a tornado or like a hurricane.
Like the eye wall is the worst,
but you're fearing the center,
you're fine. You know, I always,
I've always wondered like,
could you follow a hurricane
inside the center of the eye?
Like could you just stay
with it and be okay?
I bet you could if you moved at
a really slow speed right there,
don't move that they only move
about 10 to 20 miles an hour.
Sometimes less kind of
playing go that slow. No,
but maybe you could stay in your car,
run kind of like, you know, find a road.
If you had a really good gps system,
you've got to go, no, no, no.
Don't go northwest. Go
Northeast. Yeah. Okay.
You're going to have to go off road
or you'll die. But so that energy,
all that energy is in where
the lip, where the, you know,
if you're in the center
that you're pretty safe.
But as soon as you get sucked in right
into the wall that and you get pitched in
the limb,
that's when the lips spreads the water
that it hits and it sends you right down
to the reef. Especially in a
place like this where it's,
when you see a way that's real hollow,
it's generally a lot shallower than it is.
Um, hi. So the wave will
be 15 feet in the water,
might only be five or six feet deep.
So think of all that
energy it's going to hit.
Most of it's going to hit the reef at
some points. So that's the, you want it,
you want to try to kind of fall like
where that flips landing and then escape
under it into blue water.
What do you do when you know you're going
to hit a reef? You kind of just brace.
You don't want to hit your head. Um, for
the most part, you can tell up and down.
I mean, sometimes you lose your
equilibrium a little bit underwater,
but for the most part you can tell what
is up and down so you can feel it coming.
And I mean, I'm going to put my arms there
before I to take it on my head. Right.
Of course. So I'm, I'm like trying
to be like a cat. Like when I hit,
I want to be able to, I'll break my
hands or feet or whatever, you know,
I'm not worried about that. I don't want
to get knocked out. Right, right, right.
So I think everyone, uh, default
is to try to cover your head.
Um, you know, if you hit anywhere
else, you're kind of okay.
You just don't wanna hit your head. And
when the waves come crashing down on you,
do you lose your sense of
up and down? You can. Yeah.
But you know,
you're,
you also have your board connected
from the leash and that's usually,
that's generally going to pull
up. So you kinda know, um,
if you don't feel your board pulling,
you're kind of worried like
shut my board might hit me.
It might spear me underwater.
You know,
you can occasionally get spirit in
the face with your board or a fan or
something that's kind of spooky.
Um,
I was surfing with a guy who's
like a big brother and me.
I just traveled with Tom Carroll.
He's a two time world champion and we
were surfing Tahiti one time together and
he used to wear a helmet.
A lot of guys don't work.
Most people don't wear a helmet,
but Tom used to wear a helmet.
He was real really used to it.
But having something, you know,
an extra say inch around your
head or half inch, it's like,
it changes your judgment a little
so you gotta be used to it.
I always felt like it was weird.
It's weird for sparring too. Yeah.
It fucks with your peripheral
vision. Yeah. Yeah.
So it would mess with me when I tried
to wear them and that extra weight and
like when we're trying
to on a critical way of,
we're trying to pull in the barrel, we're,
we are dealing with inches, you know,
percentage of inches. Like just tucking
your head into that. And so you got to,
you got to kind of be really
aware of your range and your,
your ability to like Tuck
your head at certain places.
And I was never comfortable with it,
but my surfing with Tom and he wiped out
and his board spirit him in the ear and
it broke, it broke the helmet and
broke his eardrum. Jesus call.
We were just wondering like,
what the hell would have happened if
he didn't have his helmet on? You know,
like probably would've killed him,
you know,
would it definitely knocked him out and
we didn't have a jet ski with us that
day or anything. We were, you know,
500 yards or more off the beach,
half mile off the beach
somewhere at this like that.
Do you have to get it surgically
repaired? Uh, no. You? I don't think so.
I think I've never heal up.
I almost busted my eardrum like six
weeks ago in Hawaii. Just free diving.
I felt it like,
like a pinhole leak.
I could feel it like going and I kind of
got dizzy and I would just came up and
stop diving. But, um, there was a guy, um,
I got a buddy named Greg Long.
He's,
he has drown and he's
been attacked by a shark.
Not Too many people can say
those things and he's alive. Um,
how do you get saved when he drown?
Uh, that's a really crazy story,
but I'll talk about one sec.
But he did break his eardrum at mavericks
up in northern California and he just,
you just flounder. You don't know what
you think. You're swimming one direction.
Your, it's like you have liberty. Yeah.
It's like your boat's turn in and you
don't know which there's no rudder,
you know, and you're, you don't know
what's up and down and you, you know,
you think you're summing up and you're
going sideways and it's really dangerous.
There was a,
there was guy in Hawaii a couple of years
ago that drone surfing and outer reef.
He and a friend of mine caught a wave and
this guy wiped out. He didn't have all,
he had run the surf trunks and
generally will wear like even a wetsuit,
which is just then, but
it keeps you warm. Um,
and even that's enough flotation to
where if you'd got knocked out you'd
probably come to the surface.
So this guy wiped out his leash broke,
so he lost his board.
And then we think near the guys who
are out there think that he popped his
eardrum cause they said they saw him
hit the surface and start like his feet
were coming up and his hand
was coming up and you know,
he was kind of just floundering
around and then the next wave hitting,
they never saw him again,
but he was only in surf trunks.
So they didn't ever find the body,
um, because he didn't float up.
But if he just had it even just a
wet suit, just some neoprene hamper,
found the body and find him. The waves are
huge. It was, you know, it was like 40,
50 foot, whatever. But it was
really unfortunate. It was a real,
those things are really like sobering in
the surf community because we all know
each other and, um, and you know,
ultimately you're doing this for
fun and you know, it's, it's a,
it's a heavy thing, but it's crazy that
your eardrum affects you that much. Yeah.
I mean,
I've seen,
I've seen people that have inner ear
infections and they'll get dizzy walking
and you just don't know what they're
doing while they're one front in front of
the other. They want to fall sideways.
It's very strange. Yeah. Well, so Greg,
Greg Long, he'd drown actually
at a place called Cortez Bank,
which is about 120 miles off the coast
of Dana Point. It's just a [inaudible].
It's basically the top of a mountain on
an island that never hit the surface.
And, um, it was discovered when,
I think it was a nuclear ship actually
grounded itself on that reef back,
I don't know, 30 years ago or
something and caused a lot of,
caused tens of millions of dollars
of damage to the ship navy ship. Um,
and yeah, I don't know if they
had sounded the bottom by then,
it must not have known it
was there. But, um, anyways,
this wave breaks when it's really
big and um, Shane's been out there.
Shame is actually, um, I think Shane
was out there this day, not positive,
but I'm pretty sure Seamus, out during
the session there's about 15 guys out,
doesn't guys out. And uh, Greg
took off on a wave and uh,
somebody who is in front
of him on the wave,
which kind of changed his
angle a little bit, but he,
I don't think he would've
made the wave anyhow,
but it just puts them in a little
bit of a precarious situation. Um,
and he ate it and was down a long time.
This wave has just so much energy in it
because there's nothing between where
the wave started.
And this break,
like it's thousands and thousands
of feet deep that you know,
over the whole Pacific. So there's no
continental shelf to slow the wave down.
You know, if you can imagine the
east coast, we have small waves,
a big part of that.
And part of that is because most of the
storms go west to east and they don't
come towards us. But even on a
hurricane are our surf. Not that big.
Because we have a continental shelf
that goes, you know, you can go out,
you can go 20 miles and it's 70
feet deep some places. So it swells,
just drag in the Pacific, they don't drag,
there's just nothing to get in the way.
So these swells are going 35
miles an hour when they hit.
So it's a lot faster than a normal wave.
So there's all this energy in the way of,
and so when Greg went down this way,
it was probably, you know, 40
foot face or whatever, 50 face.
He was underwater and he's really calling
him. He's, you know, he's probably as,
as ready for anybody in big surf.
He's totally prepared.
He's done all the CPR
and breathing courses and
everything and he was real calm
and he said he pulled his
vast and it didn't work.
And then he pulled another one and it
didn't work and he pulled it a third time
and it didn't work. And so he's
like, Oh fuck, I'm screwed. You know,
that kind of thing. But he, at that
point you're, when you start to pull it,
you are, you're already in
a little bit of a, some,
some guys pull it right away
just to be safe on a big wave.
But some guys kind of wait and go,
I'll see if I'm able to pull this one
off and I'll save my little canister.
Cause you only have, like, some of the
vets have to two canister somehow for,
so you don't want to have to
go change your canisters over.
So if you're thinking going to make that,
you're going to get back to the
surface. Are you? You're okay,
you can handle it and you've got a
good breath. You're like, I'll just,
I won't pull it. But he pulled three
times and then he'd blacked out. And, um,
they, luckily it had really
good water safety crew and um,
I don't know that it was
his brother that saved him,
but a couple of the guys went and grabbed
dove in and pulled him up by leash.
Luckily he was to the least cause he
wasn't floating cause he didn't have the
Seo too. And then, um, he had
taken a lot of water and uh,
they had to airlift him off the boat
in height and big seas that night after
dark. Wow. And got him back to the
mainland. So did they do CPR on him?
They did CPR,
yeah.
And then the come back to consciousness
came back to consciousness,
but he was like awake while the airlift
and nobody gets fucked up. Yeah.
But guys can have secondary drowning.
Um,
we still have water in the lungs and
you're not like aware of the symptoms or
whatever. Um, I don't
know. They pump it off.
They can't just like hang by
your ankles or anything. Yeah,
I think they pump it out.
I was with a buddy in Australia a year
and a half ago and he almost drowned,
got knocked out his board, hit him
in the Chin and knocked him out cold.
And, uh, I was,
I was sitting out the back waiting for
a wave and I heard everyone kind of,
I heard another friend screaming.
Luckily the waves kind of stopped
and they were able to get to them,
pull them up on a jet ski and a,
he had taken in some water and he's
puking and coffin, all this stuff.
And I came up from behind and
I didn't see his neck. Um,
and I heard one of the guys
say, Oh, he got his board,
hit him in the neck and the throat.
And so I was expecting this artery
because, or like the throat to be open.
I was like, okay, I don't want to
look yet cause I was behind him.
I didn't want to get it to go around
them and try to look. I'm like, okay,
let's get him into the beach.
Luckily we had a jet ski because we were
about a mile off shore. And, um, I just,
I held on the jet ski and kind of,
I just squeezed on B,
we have a sled on the back of the jet ski,
like a body,
big giant bodyboard with handles.
So I just kind of straddled him,
my other friend rode the ski all the
way up on the beach. And then I thought,
okay, when we get the beach, I'm going
to have to see, this is going to be gory.
But luckily he wasn't opened up.
He just had a huge hematoma here on
his neck and he, it didn't slice him.
It just like contusion, like blunt
force. That's very lucky. Yeah.
But he spent two or three days in the
hospital because they were worried about
secondary drowning, which I don't exactly
know what secondary drowning means,
but I guess when you have a water salt
water in your lungs, it can, I don't know,
maybe from the way it
laid down or I dunno,
I should try beat super school that
right out to your living. Right. But uh,
you know what I mean? Yeah. You must
see a lot of crazy shit in the water.
Like, I've seen some crazy stuff.
Yeah. Wild life. And I mean,
you must see an amazing amount of
fish and the shark copics super.
It never ends. You know, like, I mean,
anyone in the world I meet is like, Oh,
I'm scared of sharks. Told me that
story doesn't ever end that story.
It's a primal fear like, and
eaten by a monster. You know,
you feel so vulnerable in the water.
I mean,
maybe you feel less vulnerable because
you're bored and you have a board and you
knew so quick with the board.
But like someone like, oh, you,
you are totally vulnerable if a great
white one too. Oh yeah, completely.
If a shark over, I mean, even
if was six foot shark wants you,
but that's the, that's the misconception.
You know, everyone thinks, oh,
shark death, you know, jaws
just fucked everybody up.
So I was seven or
something when I was six,
I think when jaws came out
and I watched it, you know,
I watched frickin poltergeist
when I was like 10, you know,
my parents let me watch
it, everything. And my too.
Maybe that's why I always thought there's
some boogeyman in the closet, you know,
or whatever. But the same. Yeah.
And uh, it keeps your prepared.
Maybe that's why I started
training with a dragon, you know.